L'art, c'est délicat, et ça demande pas mal de choses pour être bien fait :
une intention, de la technique, il faut que votre œuvre soit faite au bon moment,
et parfois, ça ne se passe pas comme prévu.
- (Au cadreur) ça va ?
- Ouais, ouais.
Eh bien, on peut partir de cet imprévu pour faire autre chose, une autre œuvre,
et laisser la première idée de l'artiste inachevée.
♫ MUSIQUE ♫
La première forme d'inachevé à laquelle on peut penser, c'est celle qui fait écho à l'inabouti,
comme l'œuvre qui se trouve derrière moi.
Alors, oui, là, ce transit a l'air abouti, mais pour mieux comprendre, il faut connaître son histoire.
Un transit, dans l'art funéraire, c'est une sculpture représentant un mort.
Celui-ci n'est pas n'importe lequel, puisqu'il s'agit d'un transit réalisé par Girolamo della Robbia,
suite à une commande de Catherine de Médicis.
La sculpture fut commencée en 1565, mais l'œuvre resta inachevée suite à une décision de la reine
L'œuvre était, selon elle, trop réaliste. Ce transit aurait donc dû finir sur son tombeau.
L'inachèvement prend donc ici source chez le commanditaire,
mais il peut très bien prendre source chez l'artiste lui-même.
C'est quelque chose qui est arrivé assez souvent, et l'une des raisons pouvait être
directement liée à l'argent. En 1802, le Louvre demanda à Jean-Auguste-Dominique Ingres
de copier de tableau de Poussin.
Ingres fixe la somme de 960 francs, et alors qu'il commence, il réalise qu'il voudrait augmenter la somme.
Il négocie sans succès, et, finalement, ne termine jamais sa copie.
Vous vous souvenez de Néron ? Mais si, cet empereur romain qui a fait assassiner sa mère,
et qui est peut-être responsable du grand incendie de Rome.
Vous vous en souvenez ? Eh bien, pourtant, les Romains avaient tout fait pour qu'on oublie.
Et c'est pour cela que le Sénat avait voté sa "damnatio memoriae", littéralement, "la damnation de la mémoire"
Cela consiste en l'annulation des honneurs, l'effacement du nom sur les monuments publics,
ou encore le renversement des statues à son effigie.
C'est pour cela que la tête que vous voyez ici, bien qu'il y ait l'indice capillaire de Néron,
c'est-à-dire la coiffure, n'a pas son visage. Il s'agit du visage de Titus, un autre empereur romain.
En fait, pragmatiques, pour réaliser la tête de Titus, les Romains ont réemployé celui de Néron.
Mais l'inachevé ne s'impose pas forcément, ça peut être un choix, une esthétique.
Et dans ce domaine, Michel-Ange est incontournable.
D'abord, inachevé car il n'a pas toujours fini ses œuvres, c'est le cas de l'un de ses Esclaves
pour le tombeau du pape Jules II, qu'on voit ici,
mais il y avait aussi une esthétique de l'incahevé qui est cultivée par Michel-Ange.
Chez lui, il y a deux types d'inachevés : on a pu penser que ses œuvres avaient cette esthétique
car il en produisait trop, et qu'il voulait vite passer à autre chose, mais il n'en est rien.
Certaines œuvres sont délibérément inachevées afin d'avoir une sorte de contraste de matière,
entre celles traitées simplement à la pointe et au foret, et les parties très lisses et très travaillées,
comme sur l'un des deux Esclaves. Sur certaines œuvres, ont peut voir que les parties inachevées
sont sous les parties achevées, alors qu'en sculpture, on fonctionne par retrait de matière,
et donc ça devrait être l'inverse. Donc c'est bien quelque chose qui est voulu.
L'inachevé peut donc être un choix de l'artiste, comme pour solliciter l'imagination du spectateur.
Mais si on allait plus loin que l'inachevé ?
Le concept même de l'inachevé repose sur le permanent : nous avons vu des œuvres
qui ne bougent pas, mais il faut se rappeler que ce n'est pas le cas de toutes.
Au Louvre, certaines œuvres sont si impermanentes qu'elles ne peuvent être achevées.
L'inachevé fait partie de leur essence ; c'est le cas de celle-ci : le Jardin des Tuileries.
Le Jardin des Tuileries, c'est un jardin à la française, c'est-à-dire qu'il est très carré, très ordonné,
même si on y trouve quelque bizarreries parfois : par exemple, certains arbres sont vieux,
et ne sont pas taillés à blanc rideau, comme les autres, et ressortent donc au milieu d'un tout,
qui lui est plutôt rigide : la grande difficulté de faire de l'art avec du vivant.
Et à la manière des poupées russes, il y a, dans cette œuvre géante qu'est le Jardin des Tuileries,
des multitudes d'autres œuvres. Et en voici une : l'Exèdre.
En 1658, a eu lieu la crue la plus importante jamais enregistrée. Et il faut refaire le Jardin des Tuileries.
On demande naturellement à André Le Nôtre ; il en a fait quelque chose de manifique avec un atmosphère
différente dans chaque bosquet. Puis vient la Révolution, un siècle plus tard.
Le Jardin des Tuileries devient le Jardin National, et Robespierre décide de tout réaménager.
Le style à la mode, à l'époque, c'est celui de l'Antiquité, et de tous les énormes projets qu'il a pu y avoir,
c'est celui-là qui reste.
Alors il faut imaginer qu'il n'y avait pas d'eau auparavant, et l'idée de Robespierre était de faire un endroit
où les sages vieillards pouvaient donner des conseils aux jeunes générations.
Une dernière œuvre qui change en permanence, c'est bien évidemment le Louvre lui-même :
le plus grand musée du monde. Et même si sa taille imposante lui donne cet aspect immuable,
le musée en lui-même a beaucoup évolué : il suffit de regarder la fameuse Pyramide du Louvre,
et ses 673 panneaux de verres, qui datent de 1988, mais il y a aussi ce qui n'existe plus,
comme le Palais des Tuileries, dont la construction fut lancée par Catherine de Médicis en 1564.
Il faut imaginer un immense palais, qui allait du pavillon de Flore au pavillon de Marsan.
Il a ensuite subi un incendie volontaire, en 1871, un incendie qui dura trois jours.
Le Louvre n'avait donc pas du tout ce visage-là, et je ne saurais vous dire quel visage il aura demain.
Laisser les choses inabouties, par contrainte ou par volonté, détruire pour mieux créer,
ou encore embrasser l'impermanance, pour faire de l'art quelque chose qui ne se termine jamais,
l'inachevé n'a jamais été à fuir ou à rejeter. Au contraire, il est dans l'essence même de l'art,
et on peut s'en rendre compte ici, au Louvre. Cette vidéo aurait été inachevée si je ne vous avais pas dit
qu'elle faisait partie d'un ensemble de deux vidéos. Nous avons parlé de l'inachevé,
je vous invite maintenant à parler de la femme. Et si jamais vous avez déjà vu les deux vidéos,
alors il ne nous reste qu'à espérer que ce voyage vous ait plu, et à remercier le Louvre et ses conservateurs,
qui ont su me raconter leurs plus belles histoires, et dont je n'ai été que le modeste porte parole.
N'hésitez pas à partager la vidéo si elle vous a plu, et à aller voir la chaine du Louvre,
il y a notamment d'autres collaborations avec des youtubeurs qui ne sauraient tarder,
ça va vous...
Ah... Je crois que je n'avais pas fini !